our subject for this evening
who is the enemy
who
is the enemy for god sent not his son
into the world to condemn the world
but that the world through him might be
saved
he that believeth on him is not
condemned
but he that believeth not is condemned
already because he hath not believed in
the name of the only begotten son of god
and this is the condemnation that light
is come into the world and men left
darkness rather than light because their
deeds were evil
for every wander with evil hateth the
light
neither cometh to the light unless his
deeds should be rebuked
but he that doeth truth cometh to the
light
that his deeds may be made manifest
that they are wrought in god
and
again so this third privilege to be with
you
in this week of revival i believe is the
8th of february 2022 time
moves quickly i can hardly believe we're
coming to the end of the second week in
february already but such is life
perhaps that's a sign of the end that
time moves quickly thank you very much
wherever you are
for joining us
middle bless you and i really mean that
may he bless you for your interest in
this word
but christ was step i say
the very first temptation found in
matthew chapter 4 and luke chapter 4
jesus said to satan it is written man
shall not live by brethren but by every
word that proceedeth out of the mouth of
god
ella white writes in councils and
sabbath school
page 43 paragraph two
study the word
practice the word
for it is your life
let me say that again councils on sample
school work page 43 paragraph two
five writes
study the word
practice the word obey the word for it
is your life
the very word that brought the universe
into existence the very word that
preserves the universe the very word
that shall recreate the heavens and the
earth that word is the power by which
you and i should live and so thank you
very much for your interest in god's
word for those of you watching who are
not selling the evidence
thank you for joining us we're honored
by your presence and may god lavish you
with his blessings
and doubly bless your children for those
little boys and girls who are watching
and delighted you're with us again
tonight god bless you and remember as i
say from night tonight
god and jesus are delighted
when you at that tender age give your
life to them
our subject for this evening
who is the enemy
who
is the enemy before i get into that
message i ask you always please preserve
reference make sure that there's no
disturbance in your house where you are
you most likely in the comfort of your
home monitor your children let's
preserve reference and that will please
god greatly
favor number two while i'm speaking pray
for me literally say lord
put your words in that mouth
jeremiah chapter one verse nine
then the lord put forth and touched my
mouth and the lord said unto me behold i
have put my words in thy mouth that's
what i want god to do for me if you pray
that prayer god will hear it and he will
answer
favor number three think
as you listen which means you must
concentrate and not allow one sitting
next to you to distract you think
reason as you listen to god's word
either want it in come now
let us
reason
this is an invitation from god we should
not turn down come now says god let us
who is us you and the god of heaven and
earth he's willing to reason with you
let's borrow heads now and pray
father in heaven
we come tonight as we came last night
and the night before
we come because you said come boldly the
throne of grace
we come not because we deserve blessings
we come because we need your favor we
need your mercy we need your grace
forgive us where we have offended you
today god cleanse us by applying the
blood of your son which is his life
apply the sin light to us and cleanse us
from every stain
father i humble myself before you and i
ask you very simply to use me speak
through me that the truth may travel in
the lives of those who listen tonight
i present to you those who are sick with
covet 90 if there's any such person
heal that person i pray father
completely
and for those with various aches and
pain in mercy god give them relief and
improvement in their conditions
if anyone listening to me has suffered a
loss of a family member
comfort those persons i pray because you
understand loss
father bless the little boys little
girls in a very special way put a
special blessing on our guests who are
with us dear god touch them let them
join us again tomorrow night
i pray for all nations represented by
those watching bless the government
father
every night continue to direct those
leaders further because person can a
person can only exercise power as you
permit and so bless the leaders and
remind them at all times that the most
high that's you father ruleth in the
kingdoms of men now their god
used may i pray offer no resistance in
jesus name amen
subject who
is the enemy
don't hurt people why is god doing this
to me
why is he doing that to me we view god
almost as an enemy as an adversary even
though the bible identifies who the
adversary is first peter chapter five
verse eight be sober be vigilant because
your adversary the devil as a roaring
liar walking from
he may devour he is an adversary he's an
accuser uh zechariah chapter three verse
one and he assured me joshua high priest
standing before the angel of the lord
and satan standing at his right and
resisting to oppose him our enemy is
satan not god but satan has succeeded in
getting us to see god or getting some
people to see god as the enemy and if we
see god as enemy that view of god will
affect our relationship with god because
we relate an enemy differently from the
way we relate to a friend
our subject who
is the enemy but in this presentation
i'm leaving the devil out of it and i'm
looking at the sinner
the savior and asking the question
who
is the enemy
let's go to genesis chapter 3
at williston chapter 2 read 16 17 one of
the most essential passages in the
entire bible genesis 2 16 17. listen to
the creator as he speaks to adam and
tell me if these are the words of an
enemy
and the lord
god commanded the man's thing
of every truth of the garden that is
freely eat
but of the tree of the knowledge of good
and evil thou shalt not eat of it for in
the day thou eatest thereof thou shalt
surely die if someone sees you walking
towards quicksand or right up to a
rattlesnake or right into the den of
lions and the person warns you that
person is not an enemy
and so god said in the death of ethers
thereof thou shalt surely die
this is the work of a friend
we know adam sinned by listening to
satan who was working through eve now we
go to chapter three
let's see from verse eight of verse
seven our subject who is the enemy
and the to them both were opened and
they knew that they were naked and they
saw fig together
and themselves aprons
and they heard the face of the lord
walking in the garden in the cool of the
day and adam and his wife hid themselves
from the presence of the lord god
amongst the trees in the garden they are
running from
they're fighting on why
who then is the hostas adam and eve or
god they are avoiding god now we know
from luke 19 verse 10 the son of man is
come to seek and to save that which was
lost this is what christ was doing
when he came in the cool of the day he
came to seek and to say this is not the
behavior of an enemy this is the
behavior of a friend adam and eve
because they had now been contaminated
by sin
and sin had done an immediate work of
corruption on their minds they now
avoided god
as much as they could that is the
behavior of an enemy
the creator demonstrated the behavior of
a friend
to the book of romans romans chapter 5
will reverse them
that verb very blunt is very direct it
answers the question who is the enemy
romans 5 reading verse 10 for if when we
were enemies we were reconciled to god
through the death of his son
if for
when while we were enemies we were
reconciled to god by the death of his
son the bible is very clear that we are
the enemies of god not god the enemies
of us
god
is not an enemy
god is a friend
christ
a friend not an enemy and i will take
you to some bible verses and seconds but
let me pray again father in heaven
continue to direct my thinking and my
speaking i pray in the name of jesus our
friend and your son and our savior amen
go with me to matthew chapter 9 we'll
read verse 10.
matthew 9
our subject who
is the enemy
through the first gospel
matthew was republican
the jews absolutely hated the tax
collectors because they collaborated
with the oppressive roman powers and the
jews hated them because they almost all
risked too much taxes kept some for
themselves and gave the romans what was
to them matthew was such a person a tax
collector but he met christ christ
changed his life and he went from text
collector or publican to the writer of
the first of the four gospels
tonight reading verse 10
and it came to pass as jesus said
meet in the house behold many
republicans and sinners came and sat
down with him and his disciples now in
the bible republicans
those two words are sometimes grouped
together we find that in luke chapter 15
verse 1 we find that in luke 7 verse 24
we have republicans sinners they were
clashed together because they were
looked down up by the general jewish
population as no good now the bible says
and it came to pass as jesus sat at me
in the house behold many republicans
as we say united states the scum of the
earth and sinners came and sat down with
him and his disciples they came and they
fell lost with christ why because
they saw in christ a friend not someone
who approved their behavior they saw in
christ someone who brought no
condemnation but who brought salvation
he accepted them as candidates for his
mercy his grace his salvation and so
they came and they sat down with him let
us go to
chapter 15.
luke 15
reading verse one we have a similar
story
then drew near unto him all the
republicans and sinners for to hear him
and the families and
murmurs saying this man
eateth with republicans and sinners you
receive republicans and sinners and
eateth with them the power of the
pharisees and the scribes complained
that jesus christ was a friend to the
verdict that they the pharisees and the
scribe avoided
and despised and scorned jesus
who represented god
a friend of publicans and sinners and he
is your friend right now
let's go to luke chapter seven we'll
read verse 34
7 reading verse 34 our subject who
is the enemy
luke 7
ready verse 34
son of man is come eating and drink and
you say behold a gluttonous man and a
wine bible a friend of publics and
sinners the pharisees of the scribe who
are constantly on the trail of jesus to
trap him in his words to try to find
some reason to put him out of existence
they realized as they observed that he
was a friend of sinners
now publicans and sinners
that's an expression may be used
to all sinners
from adam until this very moment
jesus christ is a friend
of sinners
and if christ is a friend of sinners
then god the father is a friend of
sinners because christ came at the
direction of the father he did what the
father told him to do he said what the
father told him to say in his
interaction with humanity jesus christ
perfectly
demonstrated the thinking the character
the behavior of the father and so the
father is a friend of sinners
who is the enemy
the sinner is the enemy
when adam's saying god did not become an
enemy of adam there are some people who
believe that christ died to remove his
eye towards sinners
god has never been an enemy of sinners
enemy of sin
god is a friend of sinners
god is an enemy of smoking which
corrupts the body god is not an enemy of
the smoker he wants to get into the
smoker and change his behavior god is
not an enemy of the drunk
that man lying in a gutter or that woman
he is an enemy of the behavior the
sinful behavior that damages the mind
which god gave to them
to contemplate spiritual things i say
again god is not an enemy of a sinner
the sinner's only true friend actually
is god
god bless all pastors and deacons and
church members and parents and cousins
and in-laws and whomever god bless them
but the closest friend a sinner has is
not a biological relative or church
official the closest friend a sinner has
is christ
a representative of god
now we can never measure the depth of
the friendship of god
because you can replace the word
friendship there with love the death of
god's love the depth of god's friendship
towards us cannot be measured but we
must still study it to get in into how
much god loves us
let us recite the most popular verse in
the bible and research has demonstrated
that john 3 16 is the most popular verse
the most widely used for god so loved
the world
so loved how much is so we don't know
that he gave his only begotten son
it is calvary that helps us to
understand to some little degree the
extent of god's love
that he gave his only begotten son that
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish but have everlasting life now the
bible says the soul that sinneth it
shall die
listen again
uh ezekiel 18 verse 4 ezekiel 18 20 the
soul that sinneth
it shall die
having said there
let us go back
to genesis 3 we read from verse 1
down to verse 7
of genesis 3 our subject
who
is the enemy and we've seen if we're
honest it is not god
we by our behavior
as enemies towards god god has come to
make his enemies his friends through the
process of conversion
genesis three
reading from verse one
now this serpent was most settled on any
beasts of the field which the lord god
had made
and he said unto the woman yea hath god
said
he shall not eat of every tree of the
garden
and the woman said unto the serpent we
may eat of the fruit of the trees of the
garden but of the fruit of the tree
which is in the midst of the garden god
hath said he shall not eat of it neither
shall he touch it lest he die
and the serpent said unto the woman he
shall not surely die for god does know
that in the day he eat thereof then your
eyes shall be opened and he shall be as
gods knowing good and evil
verse six
and when the woman saw that the tree was
good for food
and that it was pleasant to the eyes and
a tree to be desired to make one wise
she took of the fruit thereof and did
eat and gave also unto her husband with
her and he did eat and the eyes of them
both were opened and they knew that they
were naked and they sowed fig leaves
together and made themselves aprons in
verse six we have the woman eating and
the man eating what was it god said they
shouldn't do in genesis 2 16 17 in the
day thou eatest thereof thou shalt
surely die adam and eve sinned by
partaking of the forbidden fruit
now
but the bible says wherefore as by one
man sin entered into the world and so we
focus on adam jesus christ is not the
last eve or the second eve he is the
last adam or the second adam first
corinthians 15 45-47 he is the second or
the last adam not the second or the last
eve but i'm trying to tell you sin
entered the entire world and affected
the entire world when adam sinned when
he said it affected her when adam sinned
because he had been primarily given
dominion
sin affected the entire world the entire
creation the entire
area over which he'd been given dominion
as ella white white adam was crowned
king
of eden when he was created now because
by one man's sin headed into the world
we can now apply the steps the soul that
sinneth
it shall die we're still talking about
who is the enemy now we're looking at
the extent to which god is a friend
the soul that sinneth
he shall die
who sinned
adam
who was adam the first man
which means
if the soul that sinneth it shall die
the law demanded the death
of a man
because a man sinned
let me say that again
if you reason from scripture to
scripture
adam sinned romans 5 12 genesis 3 verse
a man sin
the bible says the soul that sinneth the
person who sins that person must
die adam
was a man
adam
was not man and god he was just a man
sin
is such a terrible thing that even
though the bible says that the sword has
sinned it shall die
adam could not pay for his sins
when i say pray for his sins to the
degree that he can be admitted into
god's kingdom he could not do yes he
could die all those who lost will to
that degree pay for their own sins but
what god wants is more than just payment
for sin he wants payment for sin and a
way to enter the new world to enter
heaven
only christ could do that
i repeat
now listen to this word from the servant
of the lord the revered herald um
september 21 1886 paragraph five
the refuge in herald september 21 1886
paragraph five
justice demanded the sufferings of a man
because a man sin adam
christ
equal with god rendered the sufferings
of a god
i pause for you to wrap that your head
around that statement
justice
what the law requires
demanded
not requested the law demands the death
of the sinner
justice demanded
the death
of a man why because of man's sin and
the bible says the soul that sinneth it
shall die justice demanded the
death of a man or the sufferings of a
man
jesus or christ equal with god
rendered the sufferings of a god
now we know from first timothy chapter 6
verse 16 god alone has immortality god
divinity
cannot die
let me say it again divinity
cannot die that's why the gospel is so
mysterious but we must still try to look
into that mystery in the desire of
eighties page 762 paragraph one elvis
said god did not destroy his law
and he sacrificed himself
in christ for man's redemption
i have to pause again
notice john 3 16 for god so loved the
world that he gave his only begotten son
this gift was not a distant gift this
was the method christ and the father
developed so that the father might give
himself for the sinner and he gave
himself through christ can i explain all
the details no because the plan of
salvation it baffles even angels
that's why first peter uh chapter one a
second peter chapter 1 verse 20 12 12
the angels desire to look into these
things
they want to understand
the first peter 1 21 or 112
review and herald september 21 86
paragraph five
justice demanded the sufferings of a man
why because the man's sin
christ
equal with the father or with god
rendered the sufferings of a god
when christ suffered in gethsemane
bleeding through the skin
praying three times to the father to get
him out of this
and his suffering was so great luke 22
43 tells us an angel came from heaven to
sustain him and that angel was the
highest angel in heaven that was gabriel
himself the czar of 80's pitch 693
paragraph three the angel that stands
next to god occupying the position from
which lucifer fell came to the side of
christ the highest angel the enter the
greatest power in heaven who took
lucifer's place he was sent to sustain
christ because the sufferings of christ
was so much it exceeded what a simple
human being could have suffered
that is why
in his sufferings in the garden of
gethsemane
jesus actually tasted death
for every man i'll say that again
in his sufferings in gethsemane
christ tasted death for every man
every sinner who's lost will taste death
for himself or herself
christ
who was both god and man
tasted death for every man while he was
in the garden of gethsemane suffering
our subject
who
is the enemy
the answer from the bible
we are of those who have not accepted
christ those who have not submitted to
his overtures to save them we
are the enemy
that is why christ has to come looking
for us because we're always running from
him the natural condition of the carnal
mind is to avoid god and so the bible
says in romans 3 from verse 10 but as it
is written there's none righteous lord
one there's none that understandeth
there is none that seeketh after god the
sinner does not naturally six god see
god consequently god as the divine
friend has to come seeking the sinner
that's why christ told nicodemus not
because zacchaeus in luke 19 10 as we
quoted earlier the son of man he's come
to seek and to save that which was lost
god
is a friend
you can have no closer friend
than jesus christ
who represents the father because in him
dwelleth the fullness of the godhead
bodily you can have no better friend
than god
be brought to us through jesus christ in
the sufferings on calvary in the garden
of gethsemane we see the love of the
father
in the suffering on the cross we see the
love of the father before gethsemane
before the cross all the persecution
christ endured from the pharisees and
the cries and whoever else harassed his
life we see the endurance of the father
what he was willing to suffer that he
might make a way for us to be stained in
everything christ suffered we see the
depths of the friendship of the father
my listening friend i tell you again
god is your friend
he cannot force you to be his friend but
you cannot stop him from being your
friend let me say that again god cannot
force you or force me to be his friend
but you and i cannot prevent him from
being our friends because love is love
is love and love is not changed by
surrounding hostility
let me pray again father
as i deal with the subject that the mind
is unequal to truly ample
give me the words
and the ideas
in jesus name i pray
amen
who is the enemy
we are
when christ died on that cross
the father suffered with him
as i said earlier i cannot give you the
details all i can tell you is the bible
says god was in christ reconciling the
world unto himself how does
reconciliation take place listen to
romans 5 verse 10. for if when we were
enemies we were reconciled to god by the
death of his son the foundation of
reconciliation is death
the death of christ made reconciliation
possible not reconciling god to us
reconciling us to god when we accept
that sacrifice and so the bible says god
was in christ
reconciling the world unto himself
not reconciling himself to the world god
has never been the enemy of a sinner
never even when god destroys stubborn
sinners it will be an act of justice and
mercy god has never been the enemy of a
sinner
he's a friend
and right now
as you suffer whatever you're suffering
you deal with grief
and loss
a friend of mine wrote me was it this
morning or yesterday
my father-in-law has passed that's the
son of god who wrought me he's dealing
with grief god is a friend to him
last week another friend wrote me from
another country halfway around the world
my father passed
god is afraid to that person to console
that person in the hour of grief
god is a friend you may have lost your
job
god is a friend and he who give a job to
the first man on earth adam will find
one for you but the target of god's
friendship is not so much your wallet or
whatever it is your heart god wants your
heart so that he can prepare you for a
place in his kingdom because a genuine
friend what wants what's best for his or
her friend and god wants what is best
for you salvation
is the demonstration of divine
friendship
divine love
it is a love that is self-sacrificial
what do i mean
god gave
himself
through christ
god was in christ second corinthians 5
19 reconciling the world unto himself
christ was the agent through whom god
worked out the salvation he suffered as
jesus christ suffered let me give you
the quotation again reviewing herald
september 21 1886 paragraph 5 justice
demanded the sufferings of a man christ
equal with the father rendered the
sufferings of a god how that happened i
do not understand i cannot explain what
i do know is that god was in christ
reconciling the world and reconciliation
requires suffering and death
who's the enemy
i am when i resist god
who's the enemy with great respect you
are when you resist god
who are the enemies we are romans 8 4 7
because the carnal mind is enmity
against god the carnal mind is the enemy
of god and unless that mind is changed
that enmity as we said last night will
eventually in an attempt on the very
life of god what i'm trying to tell you
god befriends those who desire to kill
him
let me say it again
god but look at jesus on the cross
father forgive them he is praying for
those killing him father forgives them
for they know not what they do that very
same spirit was sinning stephen in acts
chapter 7 verse 16 i believe it is last
verse of that chapter as he was being
stoned to death with the spirit of
christ in him stephen prayed father
forgive them he showed love for those
killing him
and on that cross
through christ
the father loved
on that cross
he threw his arms around those who were
stabbing him to death
crucifying him through jesus christ god
is not
the enemy
answer when something goes wrong in your
life
try to avoid saying why is god doing
this to me or why is god doing that to
me
i've said several times i've never heard
someone say why is the devil doing this
to me or why am i doing this to myself
it wasn't satan who made adam's sin adam
chose to sin
which may sin why we can be tempted by
satan temptation is not a command the
devil cannot force us to sin nor can god
force us to love him but tonight
god offers to you his friendship he
offers to you his love
and jesus tells us
the basis of that friendship
how can we be the friends of god
john 15
12 13.
this is my commandment that you love one
another
great love has demanded this that a man
lay down his life for his friends now
listen to verse 14 of john 15 ye are my
friends
if you do
whatsoever i command you
let's look at that from the other side
god is our friend
because he did whatever was necessary to
save us
now god says to us
you can be my friend
if you do whatever i say god did
whatever
was necessary to save us
and he tells us
to fill out this relationship you do
whatever i tell you
so i in a certain sense god obeyed
the needs that we have to be saved
he obeyed the impulse of love if i may
put it that way and love required that
something be done to save sinners and
god in a certain sense cooperated with
that urge love requires that
he yearns to save people and god
cooperated with them so in a very
limited human sense god obeyed the
impulse of love to say we must obey
the commands of god
here my friends
if you do
whatsoever i command you
god has always been the friend of the
sinner because he did whatever was
necessary to save the sinner
we can be god's friend
by doing whatever is necessary
to cooperate with the friendship of god
and that comes down to one word
obedience
tonight
i offer you a savior
who is christ the lord
i offer you a savior through whom god
the father
sacrificed himself
i cannot explain the details because
divinity cannot die but the bible says
god was in christ you and i must make it
to the kingdom that we might study this
mystery but tonight i want you to leave
this presentation
accepting that god
is your friend
and as a friend
he desires the best for you and the very
best god can do for you and for me is to
deliver us from the power of sin because
the devil is not your friend he is your
enemy but as i said earlier the devil
has twisted our mind so much we see god
is the enemy and the devil goes off
without any any blame whatsoever a
hurricane is called an act of god an
earthquake is called an act of god a
flood is an act of god a tsunami is an
act of god a snort of
snow coming down the mountain whatever
you call that is called an act of god
a forest fire is an act of god
this is not acts of god they are
overwhelmingly acts of satan but satan
has succeeded in deforming our view of a
loving god
a heavenly friend
my final words tonight
god is a friend
he's a friend of sinners
and we read in matthew 9 verse 10 and it
came to pass as jesus sat at me in the
house behold many republicans and
sinners came and sat down with him and
his disciples we read in luke 7 34 the
son of man has come eating and drinking
and he said behold a gluttonous man and
a wine bible a friend of sinners
we read in luke 15 verse 1
all the republican sinners came to be
with him and the pharisees complained
christ
as god's agent of salvation
was a friend of sinners he is your
friend right now
let's bow our heads now and speak to our
friend
father
we thank you for your offered friendship
offered in jesus christ
we thank you through christ in some
mysterious way
you give yourself because your word says
greater love hath no man than this that
a man lay down his life with his friend
and through christ you gave your life
we'll never fully understand father but
you don't call upon us to fully
understand you call upon us to accept by
faith what your word says
thank you for your friendship which
exists right now it's a friendship that
desires to save it's a friendship that
will not be satisfied if anyone is lost
if someone listening to me father has
questioned your friendship let that
person surrender to your word that you
are a friend of sinners you're a friend
of drunks you're a friend of drug
addicts you're friends of male and
female prostitutes your friend of
white-collar criminals you are a friend
of sinners right now all may anyone who
qualifies as a practicing sinner accept
that friendship for accepting your
divine friendship the person accepts
salvation
a father i hope i said something that
opened someone's eyes and gave hope to
someone listening now father bless our
guests again and bless the little
children bless those who take healed and
big god of their various ailments
particularly covet 19 and bless the
governments of nations represented by
those listening bring us back to
modernity god to hear your word again we
pray in jesus name amen